he is the owner of a global media Empire
and one of the richest men in the world
but 92 year old Rupert Murdoch is
stepping down as chairman of his holding
company news Corps we're going to have
an entirely different approach to the
paper we're going to try and sell it to
the public which I don't think the sun
has been trying for a long time born in
Australia Murdoch built his media Empire
in the UK and in print before expanding
into the lucrative U.S market his U.S
Holdings include the Wall Street Journal
and New York Post but here he's best
known as the creator of fox the first
broadcast network in the history of
Television to successfully take on the
country's big three when Fox News
Network launched in 1996 it was
something new a 24-hour cable network
with a clear ideological tilt to the
right it quickly became both profitable
and politically influential Murdoch's
Embrace of Donald Trump is credited with
helping him win the presidential
election in 2016
in the last year however Fox was forced
to pay 787 million dollars to settle a
defamation lawsuit related to its
coverage of false claims following the
2020 presidential election
shortly after Fox fired its most popular
personality Tucker Carlson Fox's
fingerprints are also all over the Trump
indictments a lot of Trump's
misinformation was spurred by Fox so
that is a part of the Legacy I think
overall though Rupert would say that his
legacy is in mergers and Acquisitions he
was always chasing the next deal and
that made sense when the media industry
was Consolidated and media was scarce
but we now live in an age of abundance
When anybody can create content at any
time Rupert Murdoch's son Lachlan CEO of
Fox News will take over the role of news
Corps chairman I think at 92 he's just
getting too old and frail to take on
those difficult public-facing tasks such
as the quarterly analysts call on
earnings turning up to face the Dominion
trial in court for a brutal
cross-examination fronting the two agms
in November so I think that uh he's
handed over partly because of his age
but also because I think Lachlan one is
requesting an opportunity to prove his
talent and capability without having
Rupert formally in the room as a voting
director of the company no word on why
Rupert Murdoch made this announcement
now as it doesn't take effect until
November ironically this week a new book
releases a biography about him entitled
the end of Fox News speculating what
will happen to the network once he's
gone but don't count them out just yet
Rupert Murdoch will retain the title of
chairman emeritus going forward Kristen
salumi Al Jazeera New York
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera